the britney spears conservatorship case  keeps getting more interesting and more  interesting most recently her  longtime manager has left and he was  followed by her  longtime court-appointed lawyer samuel  ingram now there are times when a lawyer  must resign  from representing their client but that  probably doesn't apply here things like  your client has asked you to do things  that are illegal or you're  a witness in the actual case itself  what's more likely here is that ingram  based on the notoriety from this case  and  a slew of articles that don't paint him  in a particularly great light feels that  he  can no longer represent spears and there  may or may not be anything untoward here  now in a case where a lawyer wants to  withdraw they generally have to get  approval from the court and the court  has to make sure that this withdrawal  doesn't prejudice their client so  ironically we'll see both britney and  her lawyer  in court